SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
START THE HEARING THE APRIL
NINTH COMMITTEE HEARING.
WILL CALL
CALL THE HEARING TO ORDER THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. HEARING IS CALLED TO
ORDER.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE
WILL START OFF AS A SUB
COMMITTEE MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE
AN AUTHOR.
MOVING TO MOVE TO AB NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE.
DOCTOR TRUCK.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR NINE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE.
YOU CAN SPEAK AND STAND AT THE
PODIUM SIR.
YOU'RE THE MEMBER
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND THE
MEMBER SOUTH THE OUT
TRANSPORTATION NOT COMMITTEE.
I'M HAPPY TO UP PERCENT A. B..
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE.
OPPOSE CHAIR SO REQUESTED THAT
ONE FIRST HAVE TO BILLS TO
PRESENT TO YOU. AB AT NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE DIRECTS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
MORAL WISE STUFF VEHICLES SO TO
INCLUDE THE.
ON IT ROTATING BASIS SUCH A
QUESTION ON THE.
DRIVERS
YEAH LICENSE EXAMINATION THAT
THAT CLARIFIES THAT THE DRIVING
WITHIN UNSAFE AND UNSECURE. LOW
ON THE BACK OF THE PICKUP TRUCK
IS SAKE OF VIOLATION OF STATE
LAW AND THE CAN CREATE THAT HIS
CVR TRAFFIC.
SAFETY HAZARDS DUFFEL MOTORISTS.
DURING THE WORKING SESSION.
WORKING GROUP SESSION THAT WAS.
HAL DOT AT THE YEAH ACHIEVEMENTS
OR COMMENDATION.
ONE THING THAT THE SURFACED A
WHAT'S UP THE NEED FOR INCREASED
UP PUBLIC AWARENESS. TO THE
DANGERS OF A DRIVE ARE DRIVING
UNSAFE FOR.
AND UNSECURED RULES.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE SIX UP
TO ADDRESS THE PUBLIC AWARENESS.
SIDE OF THE YARD UNSECURED THE
CARD WILL ROLL TO ISSUE.
FOURTH THIS EXAMINATION QUESTION
WOULD HELP A PROSPECT BUT
DRIVERS.
TO BE AWAY OFF THE YACHT BEING
YOURSELF UNSECURE WOULD KNOW
WHAT'S.
AND THE PENALTIES ASSOCIATE IT
WITH YOU BREAKING THE LAW.
DRIVING A WITH THE LOSE AN
UNSECURED THE CARGO CAN LEAD TO
A TERRIBLE. ACCIDENT SUCKED UP.
CAN ALTER.
THE LIVE SAW HALL FOR THE WAS SO
IMPACTED BY FLYING DEBRIS SO.
HOW CATHARINE HAWKS OF WERE NOW
WILL TESTIFY REGARDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF DESPAIR?
I RESPECTIVELY. POSSIBLE YOUR
AYE VOCAL WHEN AB NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR TRUTH
PLEASE STITCHING NAMING HERE
REPRESENTING PLEASE.
PARTLY.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN HAWKS.
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF AB NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE. AND
I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY TO HEAR ME OUT.
ON.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI FOR
INTRODUCING AB NINETEEN TWENTY
FIVE THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
AS YOU KNOW OUR SON ETHAN
HAWKE'S WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY FOURTH.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AS RESULT
OF DEBRIS ON THE FIFTY SEVEN
FREEWAY.
HE WAS JUST ONE MONTH PASSED HIS
SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
HE MADE AN IMPACT ON EVERY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS BLESSED TO
MEET HIM.
THE SEVEN HUNDRED PLUS PEOPLE
WHO ATTENDED HIS MEMORIAL
SERVICE CAN ATTEST TO THAT.
HE CONTINUES TO BE MISSED EVERY
SINGLE MOMENT OF EVERY SINGLE
DAY. BY THOSE WHO LOVED HIM.
I HOPE THAT THIS BILL WILL PASS
CAN HELP PREVENT THIS
UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDY FROM
HAPPENING TO ANOTHER FAMILY.
ON SATURDAY NOVEMBER NINETEENTH
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AS I WAS
DRIVING HE SAID.
TO PICK UP A GIRL HE LIKED FOR
THEIR VERY FIRST DAY.
I WAS PLANNING ON TAKING HIM TO
GET HIS LEARNERS PERMIT THE
FOLLOWING WEEK.
A LARGE CHUNK OF METAL CAME
THROUGH OUR WHEN CHILDREN HIT MY
SON.
IT CAME AT US WITH SUCH VELOCITY
THAT THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL OFFICERS ESTIMATE AROUND.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES PER
HOUR.
THAT I DID NOT HAVE TIME TO
REACT OR AVOID THE OBJECT.
IT TORE A HOLE IN OUR
WINDSHIELDS AND SLICE THROUGH MY
SON.
SEVERING HIS CAROTID ARTERY AND
REMOVING HALF OF THE RIGHT SIDE
OF HIS FACE.
IT THEN CONTINUED WITH SUCH
FORCE THAT IT BROKE HIS SEAT
CAUSED CONSIDERABLE DAMAGE TO
THE STEEL OF THE REAR PASSENGER
DOOR.
FINALLY COMING TO A STOP IN THE
REAR PASSENGER SEAT. WHERE THE
CHP OFFICERS FOUND IT?
THIS CHUNK OF METAL WEIGHING AN
ESTIMATED FOUR TO SEVEN POUNDS.
WAS LAUNCHED AT US FROM WHERE WE
KNOW NOT THAT THE CHP BELIEVED
THAT IT WAS LIKELY DEBRIS. WHICH
HAD FALLEN OFF ANOTHER VEHICLE
AND THEN HAVING BEEN LEFT IN THE
ROAD.
WHO IS ELEVATED BY YET ANOTHER
VEHICLE AND HURL HURLED AT OUR
VEHICLE AND MY CHILD?
MY SON NEEDS AND WAS INCREDIBLY
STRONG I FULLY BELIEVE THAT ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUAL IN HIS
CONDITION WOULD HAVE BEEN LOST
IN THE CAR THAT DAY.
BUT MY ETHAN HUNG ON.
WELL I DROVE HIM TO THE HOSPITAL
APPLYING PRESSURE TO HIS WOUND
THE DAMAGE TO HIS CAROTID ARTERY
PATA STROKED THE RIGHT
HEMISPHERE OF HIS BRAIN.
HIS JOB WAS SHATTERED IN HIS
FACE WAS TORN. FROM HERE ALLEN.
HE WASN'T SURGERY FOR OUR SIMPLY
JUST TRYING TO STOP THE
BLEEDING.
AND CLOSE HIS FACE.
LATER PLANS TO REBUILD A NEW JOB
FROM ISRAEL BEEN REPAIRED THE
OTHER INJURIES SUSTAINED WOULD
HAVE WAITED UNTIL MUCH FARTHER
ALONG IN ITS RECOVERY. HAD HE
MADE IT THAT FAR.
TWO AND A HALF HOURS FOLLOWING
THAT FIRST SURGERY HE WAS RUSHED
BACK FOR ANOTHER THREE AND A
HALF HOURS OF SURGERY.
TO HAVE THE RIGHT SIDE OF HIS
SKULL REMOVED SO THAT THE
SWELLING IN HIS BRAIN COULD FIND
SOME RELIEF.
HE LOST PART OF HIS RIGHT
FRONTAL OPEN THAT SURGERY HAVING
BEEN CRUSHED BY THE SWELLING.
AND SUSTAINING TOO MUCH DAMAGE
TO SAY.
OVER THE NEXT FIVE DAYS EATEN
INTO OUR TO MORE PROCEDURES TO
INSERT PROBES.
INTO HIS BRAIN TO MONITOR
SWELLING IN ACTIVITY.
ALONG WITH OTHER MEDICAL EFFORTS
TO SAVE HIS LIFE.
THE BEST TRAUMA TEAM
NEUROSURGERY TEAM AND I SEE YOU
TEAM DID EVERYTHING WITHIN THEIR
POWER TO TRY TO SAVE MY SON.
FOR FIVE DAYS HE FOUGHT TO CLING
TO LIFE ULTIMATELY.
EATEN SUCCUMBED TO HIS INJURIES
AT FIVE THREE AM. THANKSGIVING
MORNING.
UPON LEAVING THE HOSPITAL AFTER
LOSING MY SON.
THE CAR EAT THEN SISTER AND
FATHER WRITING IN.
ALSO HAD A CLOSE CALL ON THE
SAME FIFTY SEVEN FREEWAY.
AT APPROXIMATELY THE SAME
LOCATION GOING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION. NORTHBOUND.
A PIECE OF WOOD SIMILAR TO A TWO
BY FOUR FLUID THE VEHICLE'S
WINDSHIELD. AND ALMOST TOOK OUT
THE REST OF MY FAMILY.
THIS HAS TO STOP.
I SPEAK TO YOU TODAY NOT JUST ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF ANY AND BUT.
ALSO ALL OF THE OTHER FAMILIES
WHO CAN'T BE HERE TODAY.
THE ONES WHO HAVE BEEN LOST.
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN INJURED HAD
PROPERTY DAMAGE IN THOSE WHO.
ARE MISSING LOVED ONES TODAY
BECAUSE OF OTHER PEOPLE NOT
SECURING THEIR LOADS.
EVERY SINGLE DAY I SEE VEHICLES
DRIVING WITH UNSAFE FLOATS
INDIVIDUALS WHO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED HE SAID. REGULARLY
APPROACH ME TO REPORT THAT THEY
SAW AND SAFE VEHICLES ARE ITEMS
LEFT IN THE ROADWAYS. REPORTING
NEAR MISSES ON THEIR WAY TO
WORK.
DESCRIBING THE ACCIDENT THEY SAW
UNFOLD BEFORE THEIR EYES DUE TO
DEBRIS ON THE ROADWAYS AND
HIGHWAYS.
FAR TOO OFTEN PEOPLE FIND
LADDERS FURNITURE PIPES TOOLS
PAULA MANNER OF DEBRIS ON THE
ROADWAYS AND HIGHWAYS.
HAVING TIME ENOUGH TO TRY TO
AVOID SUCH ITEMS HAS A HIGH
PROBABILITY OF CAUSING ANOTHER
COLLISION. WITH ANOTHER VEHICLE.
MORE OFTEN HOWEVER THESE
MOTORISTS ARE TRAVELING AT SUCH
SPEEDS.
THE DAY UNWITTINGLY HIT THESE
ITEMS CAUSING DAMAGE TO THEIR
VEHICLES. AND ARE CATAPULTING
THESE ITEMS. INTO SOME OTHER
UNSUSPECTING MOTORIST OR
PASSENGER LIKE MY SON.
THIS IS LIKELY WHAT HAPPENED TO
EAT THEN AND WHAT HAPPENS TO
MANY MORE.
BUT WE CANNOT LET THIS CONTINUE.
SOMETHING MUST BE DONE TO
PROTECT THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA.
I BROUGHT WITH ME TODAY JUST.
THREE PHOTOS OF.
EVERYDAY PEOPLE ON.
JUST NORMAL ROADS ON MY WAY TO
WORK.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE SEEKS TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON THE
HAZARDS OF TRAVELING WITH UNSAFE
UNSECURED LOADS.
THIS KNOWLEDGE HAS THE POWER TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF ANOTHER
TRAGEDY LIKE THIS HAPPENING TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
MAYBE SOMEONE YOU LOVED MAYBE
SOMEONE YOU KNOW.
THIS INFORMATION WILL LEAD TO
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE
WHO DISREGARD THE LOT BECAUSE
DAMAGE OR INJURES SOMEONE WITH
THEIR NEGLIGENCE. AND WILL
HOPEFULLY MAKE OTHERS THINK
TWICE BEFORE CARRYING AND
SECURED CARGO. THAT MAY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO KILL SOMEONE ELSE'S
CHILD. GRANDCHILD PARENT SIBLING
OR FRIEND.
VOTING YES IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE MAY PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT YOUR
LOVED ONES.
YOUR FRIENDS CO WORKERS AND
VOTING CONSTITUENTS.
A REMARKABLE HUMAN BEING MY SON
ETHAN HAWKE'S IT NO LONGER HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO MAKE OUR WORLD A BETTER
PLACE.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TODAY.
IN COUNTLESS LIFE'S.
BY SUPPORTING AB NINETEEN TWENTY
FIVE.
PLEASE HELP PREVENT ANOTHER
FAMILY FROM EXPERIENCING THIS
EXCRUCIATING LOS AN UNTHINKABLE
TRAGEDY.
PLEASE HELP PREVENT YOUR FAMILY
FROM SUFFERING THIS PAIN. AND
GRIEF.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND MAKE CALIFORNIA
A SAFER PLACE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR HIM.
HAN KOMMER TERRIBLY SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS BUT WE'RE GONNA DO A
LITTLE BIT HOUSEKEEPER GOING
DOWN ANSWER A CALL THE ROLL FOR
CORDLESS.
FRAZIER.
YOU'RE
PHONE HERE AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HERE HARPER. MATHIS
THERE MEDINA HERE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
REFORM.
THIS WILL.
GROWTH FIRST BY OF SOME REMEMBER
HARPER SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
BAKER.
TOUCH CHOICES YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I THOUGHT YOU KNOW.
KNOCKED ON THIS PARTICULAR ONE.
BUT NO WE TO PASS.
NAM MANY YEAH.
A QUESTION TO A SO CALLED THEN
NOT AND THEN I HAVE. MOVED TO
THOSE YEAH SO I ASK YOUR.
.
I VOTE ON THIS IN THE OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THROUGH LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR VOICE AN OPINION
ON THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SIMILARLY.
JUST WISH TO THANK DOCTOR CHOI
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND VISITING WITH US BUT LAST
YEAR IN IN THIS YEAR ABOUT THANK
YOU MOM.
FOR TELLING US ABOUT ETHAN
THERE'S NOTHING YOU COULD HAVE
DONE DIFFERENTLY.
AND FOR BEING HERE TO SHOW PROOF
IS CALLED ROCK.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER HIGH FRAZIER
AYE FONG. FONG AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER AYE HARPER AYE MATHIS AYE
AYE MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
BILL IS CLEARLY THE RULE THAT
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DOCTOR
CHOI WAS LIKE HIM MOVE ON TO.
AB NINETEEN OH SEVEN PLEASE.
AND CENTERS HERE IN THE TECH
MEMBERS.
NOW.
THIS IS OUR AND OTHER RELATED
ARE BEING USED TO UNSECURED LORD
MATTERS.
.
THIS SPELL LA A. B. NINETEEN OR
SELF ON.
WOULD CREATE.
S. A PARITY IN THE LAW GO TO
ROADS. AND THEREFORE
OUGHT TO ACCOUNT BUT FOR
PREVENT.
ACCIDENTS INJURIES AND OF
FATALITIES DUE TO UNSECURED KNOW
WHAT'S BECOMING LULU CELLPHONE
CALIFORNIA STREETS AND HIGHWAYS.
EACH YEAR.
MANY PEOPLE ARE KILLED ONE
INJURED ONE CALIFORNIA FREEWAYS
SO WHAT IS IT THAT.
WALKER FREQUENTLY.
JUST ABOUT EVERY DAY AND I
LISTEN TO US DAILY NEWS. I HEAR
SEVERAL TIMES OF SUCH OBJECTS
THAT THE FOR FALLING OFF THE
FREEWAY OF ALL. MORNING OFF DIAZ
OPEN COBOL TRUCKS OPEN THE
FREEWAYS.
A RECENT STUDY
SAFETY ISSUE AT THAT A REPORT
TITLED. THE CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
PONY.
HAS.
THIRTY FIVE.
PENALTY.
PER.
LONG SORRY.
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS. INDEPENDENT
KEEPER INCIDENTAL OF UNSECURED
THE ITEMS.
AB NINETEEN OH SEVEN WOULD
INCREASE THE PENALTIES SO TO
EIGHT MANY MORE OF.
FIFTY DOLLARS A BOOK IS DONE.
I FOR UNSECURED UP OBJECTS
WHEN VEHICLES.
THIS IS SO MERELY A FIFTEEN
DOLLARS TO INCREASE.
YEP DOT WHERE THE SAN.
THE RIGHT MESSAGE TO DETER
INDIVIDUALS SO FROM DRIVING
WITHOUT A SECURE REPORTS.
AB IT NINETEEN OR SEVEN WOULD TO
ENSURE THAT. BASS SPINE FOR SUCH
AN UNSECURED OR THE FIRE
NATION'S SELF WOULD BE
COMMENSURATE.
I WITHOUT OF OUR DRIVING WITH
YOU UNSCHOOLED DOGS.
AB IN NINETEEN OH SEVEN OR THAT
DELINEATE.
THE PENALTY OF US SUCH A
VIOLATION OF OUR DRIVING WITHIN
ONCE YOU A SON UNSECURED LOW.
RATHER THAN NOW.
HAVING THE OF VIOLATIONS OF BE
PENALIZED SO THROUGH OUR
KATCHOR.
PENALTY.
SEVERAL.
CONSTITUENTS FAMILIES AND A
SCHOOL.
SCHOOL RESEARCH AND THE MORE THE
RECESSION HAVE CONTACTED OUR
OFFICE
VOICING SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
TRAGICALLY THERE ARE COUNTLESS
SUCH INCIDENTS.
THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA.
IN WHICH THE BREEZE SO ALTHOUGH
UNSECURE MATERIALS SO HAVE
COMPLY.
FLYING OFF THE VEHICLES.
AND I HAVE IT IN YOUR.
CHAIR. AND ACOSTA ACCIDENTS SO
ONE I WILL HIGHWAYS. AND
DISTRICTS.
IN NOVEMBER OF A TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
AS YOU HEARD. ORNEA. ONE MONTH
AFTER HIS SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
ETHAN HAWKE'S WAS SO ONE SUCH A
VICTIM.
WHEN A LARGE P. SUFFER MEADOW
THE PREVIOUS SELF RULE AWFUL
VEHICLE.
TRUCKS AND UP WENT THROUGH. THE
WINDSHIELD OF THE CAR.
THAT THOUGH HIS SAW MOTHER
SITTING RIGHT HERE WAS SO
DRIVING.
OUR IN WHICH A DEFENDANT WAS A
PASSENGER.
AND THE SEVERED ETHAN'S SO.
TARA TWO. ARTERY ULTIMATELY
COSTING IS SO TRAGIC STEPS.
IN ADDITION.
S. SO RECENTLY ASKED ON
WEDNESDAY. MARCH FOURTEENTH.
OF THIS YEAR.
A TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD MAN WAS
SET TO.
WHILE DRIVING I'LL.
WHEN I'M MEADOW PIECE OF OUR.
THE BREEZE FLEW THROUGH HIS SUB
WINDSHIELD.
ON TWO HUNDRED TEN FREEWAY. IN
WADI IS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS ARE ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
OF OUR YOUNG PERSON WAS KILLED
THE FROM THIS SELF NINE DEGREES.
THIS FATALITIES.
CAN BE.
PREVENTED
IT'S A PREVENTABLE.
AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO. ASK MRS
HOXA
TO ADD. ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
ON THIS BILL AND THEN ALSO.
YOU MIGHT SEE ARE OUR IF FUND
HAWKS SO.
WRISTBAND รณ WHEN YOUR TIES
TIRES SO. AND THAT THIS IS SOME
MEMORY. ARE OF OUR.
THIS YOUNG PERSON SUB PASSING
AWAY. FROM US SUCH OF YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATE DOT FLYING TO
BREEZE.
SO.
AGAIN ONCE AGAIN NINETEEN WAS
TO HAVE ONE AS A RELATED UP AND
SECURE. PUBLIC SAFETY OBVIO AND.
NUYS AND SO NOW.
THE SAD TO UP PERCENT AGAIN ONCE
AGAIN CAPS LOCK AT THREE O'CLOCK
SO. FOR HER EXPERIENCE OF MY
SECOND ON THIS BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON THE SUPPORT OF
AB I NINETEEN OR SEVEN.
THANK YOU.
I THINK HE DOES ENJOY.
SOCKS.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN HOCKS.
AND AS I SAID IN MY PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY MY SON ETHAN HAWKE'S.
JUST WHAT MONTH AFTER HIS
SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY WAS TAKEN
FROM US.
WHAT SHOULD OF BEEN ONE OF THE
BEST DAVIS OF HIS LIFE?
GOING ON A FIRST DATE WITH A
GIRL THAT HE LIKED.
STARTED VOLUNTEERING AT THE FOOD
THINK THAT MORNING TRYING TO
HELP OTHERS.
AND TRYING TO FEED PEOPLE WHO
NEEDED TO BE FED.
HIS DAY ENDED WITH AN
UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDY IS YOU KNOW.
I'M A FRIEND OF OURS POSTED ON
DEFENSE FACEBOOK IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
AN EXPECTANT MOTHER.
TEN DAYS BEFORE HER DUE DATE.
DIE THE SAME WAY IT'S HEATH BEN.
THIS HAPPENS FAR TOO OFTEN.
TODAY THE FIGHT FOR DRIVING WITH
AN UNSECURED LOAD IS JUST THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS.
SO EVEN IF SOMEONE GETS HURT OR
KILLED. THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS IS
ALL OUR SAFETY IS WORTH.
AB NINETEEN OH SEVEN SEEKS TO
INCREASE THE FINE. AS A
DETERRENT.
WE JUST WANT THE PUBLIC TO BE
MORE CAREFUL.
AB NINETEEN OH SEVEN SEEKS TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF ANOTHER
TRAGEDY LIKE THIS HAPPENING TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
HARSHER PENALTIES IN PLACE FOR
IRRESPONSIBLE TRANSPORT OF LOOSE
ITEMS ON OUR HIGHWAYS AND
ROADWAYS.
WILL ACT AS A DETERRENT.
ASKING FOR. INCREASED SCIENCE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND HOW
SERIOUS THIS IS.
TO PROTECT YOUR FAMILIES.
YOUR LOVED ONES
YOUR FRIENDS.
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE WHO
DISREGARD THE LAW. AND CAUSE
DAMAGE OR INJURE SOMEONE ELSE
WITH THEIR NEGLIGENCE WILL
HOPEFULLY MAKE OTHERS THINK
TWICE BEFORE CARRYING AND
SECURED CARGO. THAT MAY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO KILL SOMEONE ELSE'S
CHILD. GRANDCHILD PARENT SIBLING
OR FRIEND.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND SPEAK TO YOU TODAY.
WHO HAVE ALSO EXPERIENCED THIS
LOSS?
MY MOTHER.
ABOUT TWO YEARS BEFORE WE LOST
ETHAN WAS DRIVING WHERE THE
FIFTY SEVEN IN THE SIXTY MARCH.
ROUND DIAMOND BAR. AND A PALLET
TRUCK.
ONE OF THE PICTURES THAT I GAVE
YOU EARLIER SHOWED HOW THEY
STACK THEM.
THREE CARS HIGH AND DON'T SECURE
THEN ONE OF THOSE PALLETS FLEW
AT HER SPINNING AROUND LIKE A
SAW BLADE. AND SHE ALMOST HIT
SOMEONE ELSE TRY TO AVOID IT.
THIS IS EVERYONE'S SAFETY.
PLEASE
PLEASE MY SON ETHAN HAWKE'S IS
GONE.
AND NOTHING CAN BRING IT BACK TO
ME.
AND THE OTHERS WHO LEFT IN SO
DEARLY.
BUT AB NINETEEN OF SEVEN HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO SAVE SOME OTHER
FAMILY FROM EXPERIENCING THIS
EXCRUCIATING LASSEN UNTHINKABLE
TRAGEDY.
PLEASE I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
SAFETY OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
THE SAFETY OF YOUR FAMILIES.
PLEASE SUPPORT EP NINETEEN OH
SEVEN.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
I'M.
A DUTCH TOWARD YOU HAVE ANYONE
ELSE
YOU CAN FAVOR OF THIS MELLOW.
I WAS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
BAR IN THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL.
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
UP WE SEE TODAY TAKE YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIRK BLACKBURN NOW WE
HAVE TO THE WESTERN STATES
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
WSTM MEMBERS HALL OVER SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE DIRT ROCKS
SAND AND GRAVEL IN THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY W. ESTIMATE MUST
BE OPPOSED TO AB NINETEEN NO
TWO.
FIRST OFF OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES GO OUT TO THE HAWKS
FAMILY. AND WE APPLAUD THE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR CONTINUING
TO TO BRING AWARENESS IS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
HOWEVER A WSDL WST BELIEVES THAT
THE CURRENT FIVE BASS FINE OF
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS. WHICH WHEN
FACTORING AND ALL THE DISH AT
ALL PENALTY ASSESSMENTS AND
SURCHARGES AS UP TO MORE LIKE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
DOLLARS.
ALREADY SERVES AS A SUFFICIENT
ECONOMIC TO TURN.
THE PROJECT INTENDED EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN NO SEVEN IS MISGUIDED
AS OURS OF NO EVIDENCE THAT
INCREASED IN THESE PENALTIES.
WOULD DETER THIS CUT TYPE OF
CONDUCT.
INSTEAD W. STA SUPPORTS EFFORTS
TO INCREASE PUBLIC EDUCATION.
LIKE WITH AB NINETEEN TWENTY
FIVE.
WHICH WILL LEAD TO INCREASED
AWARENESS AND ARE MORE LIKELY TO
COULD CURTAIL SUCH BEHAVIOR
THANK.
AS ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
IS THERE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
A SEEING AND NO QUESTIONS OF.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR.
.
I MISS HARPER AS TAKEN FROM A.
FIST ATROCIOUS CLOSE.
OKAY THANK YOU MEMBERS SO.
THIS YOU HAVE SEEN OUR IN THE. A
PO.
ADULT INCREASE OF THE FINE IS
OUR ONLY SYMBOLIC VERY NEGATIVE
CHEN TO EVEN ADDING ON THE COURT
COURSE TO HIS SCHOOL NOT PSTN
LA.
GOING TO FIFTY SOMETHING DOLLARS
ARE ON THE WAY TO LOWER OF THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. DESIST ARE NOT.
PENALIZING ANY LIVELIHOODS UP
UP UP. IDEA TRUCKING A MEMBERS.
SO WHO ARE IN IN THE IN THE
INDUSTRY I HOWEVER AT THIS IS
SUCH A MASSIVE CHIP THAT THAT WE
ARE CONCERNED AND THAT IS A
STRONG MESSAGE WE CAN SEND. FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SORT AB YEAH I
CAN WILL SEVEN. EIGHTEEN SEP TO
KEEP OUR STREETS
HIGHWAYS AND I'LL OWNER LIVES
SAFE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
I THINK YOU DON'T CHOI.
AS I TYPE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MISSION IS DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
AND WE ARE CURRY NO BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHAIRMAN.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA KNOWN AS AREA AND.
O'DONNELL.
OTHER VOTER IS THREE TO TWO WILL
CONTROL. THANK YOU HAVE TRIED.
THEM THANK YOU MEMBERS.
BUT MR CHAU SENIOR IT'S JUST
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF ITS
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. AB TWENTY
FIFTY EIGHT WOULD ENSURE THAT
THE STATE HAS RELIABLE DATA
PERTAINING TO THE NUMBER OF
CANNABIS DO YOU AYE ARREST THAT
OCCUR ANNUALLY. THIS DATA WILL
BE HELPFUL IN ASSISTING THE
STATE TO COME UP WITH AN
INFORMED POLICY AROUND CANNABIS
DE WISE. AS WE TRANSITION INTO
THE LEGALIZED CANNABIS MARKET.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS NO WAY
TO DETERMINE HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
ARRESTED FOR CANNABIS STEEL Y.
ANNUALLY.
BECAUSE EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITY TRACKS THIS DATA
INDIVIDUALLY AND INDEPENDENTLY.
AND THERE CURRENTLY ISN'T A
REQUIREMENT TO REPORT THE SAYS
THAT.
AS WE HAVE SEEN IN OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE LEGALIZED CANNABIS AN
INCREASE IN CANADA'S DRUG
DRIVING. CAN BE EXPECTED DUE TO
LEGALIZATION ACCORDING TO THE
DENVER POST AFTER LEGALIZATION
THE STATES OF COLORADO AND
WASHINGTON. BOTH EXPERIENCED AN
INCREASE IN CANADA SO INVOLVED
ACCIDENTS ARE INVOLVING
FATALITIES WITH THE WASHINGTON
STATE EXPERIENCING AN EIGHTY ONE
PERCENT INCREASE IN THESE
ACCIDENTS.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND COLORADO
EXPERIENCE THE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE PERCENT INCREASE IN THESE
ACCIDENTS BETWEEN A YEAR TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND TWENTY SIXTEEN.
SO IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE HOUSE ACCURATE AND
RELIABLE DATA ON CANNABIS DO YOU
WISE. THIS BILL AB TWENTY FIFTY
EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REPORT.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
NUMBER OF ARRESTS MADE IN WHICH
CANNABIS WAS SUSPECTED TO BE THE
SUBSTANCE OR ONE OF THE
SUBSTANCES OF WHICH THE OTHER
PERSON HAS SO WAS DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF OUR.
HOW THE DOJ WOULD THEN BE
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A FORM A
WILL PRESCRIBE A FORMAT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO REPORT TO STATE
OF BY? A APRIL FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE DATA CANNABIS
DO YOU AYE ARREST DATA TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE D. M. V.. ANNUAL
REPORT ON THE EFFICACY OF
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS FOR
PERSONS CONVICTED OF A DUI.
ARE CURRENTLY THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I WE GOT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU RIGHT
I'LL MOVE APPROVAL.
I DO ANYONE THAT WOULD SPEAK IN
FAVOR.
I MISS CHAIR MEMBERS TIM CHIANG
WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AYE I BELIEVE THE
AUTHOR HAS COVERED EVERYTHING WE
JUST ENERGY RIGHT VOTE FOR THIS
MEASURE.
THE EMBARRASSED ON BEHALF OF
TRIPOLI OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
NEVADA AND UTAH AND SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER AT A AT ANY
BECAUSEI WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
A TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
A SHOWS THAT CLOSE I ASK HER
ABOUT THAT VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR A FIRST FOR MISTER
DALY AND A SECOND MR MEDINA.
OF WHICH I CULTURAL CENTER.
THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FONG FONG I AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR
CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY AYE DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER AYE HARPER AYE MATHIS
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL.
THE VOTE THE SIX ZERO WILL KEEP
THEM CALLING ROLE. THAT VERY
MUCH MEMBERS
.
UNLESS SOMEBODY I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL
.
I'M THIS WE DO NOT LEADERS.
IS PRESENTING AB.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY OUR PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX SIXTY.
SIXTY SIX.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
AND AND ACCEPTING THAT I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT
PROTECTS. STUDENT PRIVACY.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX.
ESTABLISHES AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT WHICH WILL MEASURE
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES
THE STUDENTS AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO RECORDS
IN PLACE THAT MEASURE LONG TERM
STUDENT SUCCESS.
KRIS STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATED
AND CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES THE
COLLABORATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
ATTRACT WAGE DATA
SO THAT CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS CAN BE
IMPROVED. TO YIELD OPTIMAL
RESULTS FOR ITS STUDENTS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF OF
A. B..
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX.
ARE LARA MATTOON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND OTHER
HAND THOUGH ESPINOZA WITH THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT. OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
THE BILL.
SECOND.
A PLEASE INTERNET.
LARA MATERIAL AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BUT CANCERS OFFICE THAT
OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS IS THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
OUR BOARD VOTED TO ENDORSE THE
CHANCELLOR'S VISION FOR SUCCESS
WITH CALLS OUT SIX. GOALS. A ONE
OF THOSE GOALS FOCUSES ON
INCREASING BY TWENTY PERCENT THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO OBTAIN AN
INDUSTRY VALUED CREDENTIAL. ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT WE DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT OUR PROGRAMS ARE
ALIGNING WITH INDUSTRY NEEDS IS
BY DOING A DATA MATCH THAT
ALLOWS US TO LOOK AT WAGE GAINS
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
IT IS THEN PROVIDED IN THE
AGGREGATE FOR INSTITUTIONS FOR
THE PUBLIC AND FOR POLICY MAKERS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW WELL OUR
PROGRAMS ARE DOING IN SERVING
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND THE
NEEDS OF THE WORKFORCE.
.
I APPRECIATE THE.
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE THAT RESULTED IN THE
AMENDMENT TO PROTECT SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS AND MAINTAIN
PRIVACY AYE WITH THAT.
WE ASK FOR YOUR I DON'T THINK
YOU.
HAVE JUST BEEN US ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARDS THEM. CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWO SIX SIX SIX.
ARE A LOT OF THIS WORK CAME OUT
OF THE JOINT ADMINISTRATION OF
THE ADULT ED BLOCK PRO.
GRANTS
A BETWEEN THE CHANCES OFFICE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
LOOKING AT WAGE AND.
INCOME DATA.
Y. AFTER LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
THE GOALS.
WITH REGARDS TO THE ADULT
EDUCATION POPULATION WE WERE LET
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
STEPPED BACK AND TOOK A LOOK AT
HOW THIS COULD.
FEED INTO OUR OUR OUR NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THAT'S
REPORTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS DASHBOARD. AND WITHIN
THAT DATA. ONCOLOGY CAREER
INDICATORS ARE COLLECTED AND SO
WE ENVISIONED THIS DATA TO BE
INFORMING FORMING A LOT OF THAT
INFORMATION WHICH WOULD INCLUDE.
IF THIS BILL WERE TO PASS THE
COLLECTION OF.
THE NUMBER OF THE NUMBER OF
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS THAT
ENTERED THE WORKFORCE RIGHT
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL. THE TYPE OF
INDUSTRY A WAGE STATE.
SO I DON'T LET LET US LOOK
ELECT SCHOOLS LOOK AND SEE OUR
STUDENTS PURSUING C. T. CAREER
IS.
ARE THEY.
GETTING JOBS THAT ARE ALIGNED
TO SOME OF THE CAREER A CT
COURSES OR INDUSTRY SECTOR
CERTIFICATES THEY'VE RECEIVED.
ALSO GO BACK IN INFORMED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS ARE
WHETHER.
THE PROGRAMS BEING OFFERED IS
FULFILLING OF THEIR LOCAL NEEDS.
AND ALSO.
.
HELPING THEM OF FUTURE PLAN UP
PLAN OUT.
OTHER PROGRAMS AND SO FORTH SO
WITH THAT.
.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I THINK A MUCH IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE FROM THE PUBLIC THAT WE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE FOOTHILL DE ANZA
AND KERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
ARE THERE ANY.
INDIVIDUALS THAT LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON THIS
BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I'M
THINK YOU MISSED MEDINA. AYE
MEASURE LIKE IT'S SEE THIS
HIGHER EDUCATION AS WELL WITH
BOTH WELL BY TEN TO A COUPLE
QUESTIONS REAL AND THEY ARE
ABOUT PRIVACY CONCERNS.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH SO SECURITY
NUMBERS.
FIRST ONE IS.
IS WHAT WHAT OTHER ALTERNATE WHY
SO SECURITY NUMBERS
WHERE THERE ARE OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH TO GET THIS INFORMATION.
AVAILABLE.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES CURRENTLY
HAS THE DATA SHARING AGREEMENT
WITH THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOP.
IMPLEMENT ABOUT MY DEPARTMENT
AND WHAT WE UNDERSTAND FROM THAT
EXISTING DATA SHARING AGREEMENT
IS THE ONLY WAY THAT THEY CAN DO
THIS WAGE FILE MATCHES WITH THE
FULL SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. WE
HAVE EXPLORED OTHER IDEAS LIKE
JUST USING THE LAST FOR DOING A
FUZZY MATCHING WE'VE BEEN TOLD
THERE'S NOT AN OPTION THERE.
WELL I'M SORRY TO HEAR THAT
ANSWER BECAUSE I'VE LOOKED INTO
EDT A LOT.
WITH WHAT THEY DO WITH SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS. AND.
THERE REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY
STILL USE FULL SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS INCLUDING FOR MAILING
INFORMATION TO PEOPLE THAT HAS
THEIR FULL ADDRESS FULL NAME IN
FULL SO SECURITY NUMBERS.
AND MET WITH THEM DIRECTLY TO
SEE HOW THEY CAN TAKE CARE OF
THAT IN WHY THEY CAN'T USE.
ONLY FOUR DIGITS AND I. AM SORRY
THAT THAT'S THE BEST WE CAN DO
FOR SAY WHY WOULD YOU HOLD IT
WHOLE NUMBERS WE SHOULDN'T.
I MEAN I REALLY THINK. IT'S EVEN
A QUESTION MARK IF WE SHOULD USE
THE LAST FOUR DIGITS BUT AT A
MINIMUM WE SHOULD NOT BE
CONTINUING TO SPREAD THE
PROBLEM.
AND AM EDT HE'S GOT ITS OWN
PROBLEMS ON THIS SAYS THEY THINK
THEY'RE GONNA TAKE SIX OR SEVEN
YEARS TO DIG OUT OF IT.
THAT'S THE BEST THEY CAN DO WE
SHOULD NOT BE PUT IN I
PERSONALLY VERSION OF BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT.
OF MOTOR VEHICLES RIGHT DOWN
THAT SAME PATH.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE ARE
REFERRING TO A VERY PRIVATE
NUMBERS THAT ARE CONSTITUENTS
ALREADY ARE VERY CONCERNED GET
SHARED NOT JUST BY GOVERNMENT
BUT IN GENERAL.
WHICH GOES TO MY NEXT QUESTION
AND THAT IS HAVE YOU THOUGHTS OR
COULD YOU DO GIVEN THE.
HEIGHTENED PRIVACY CONCERNS
AND HOW VERY IMPORTANT IT IS WE
DON'T JUST READ DO BAD POLICY
AND BAD USE OF SO SECURE MEMBERS
BY THE STATE. HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED AN OPT IN.
OR ARE GETTING THE INFORMATION
DIRECTLY WITH PERMISSION FROM
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE SU SU
SECURITY AND SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS ARE TRYING TO GET
EMPOWERING. THEM TO CONTROL
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
THEIR NUMBERS.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS.
AND MINIMUM A BEST PRACTICES AND
EIGHT I DON'T IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT OPTION AND IF NOT WHY
THAT'S NOT MORE FEASIBLE.
IF.
SO UNDER EXISTING PRACTICE ARE
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE YES YOU
AND YOU SEE ALL USE THIS
EXISTING MECHANISM. WITHOUT AN
OPT IN IN THE INFORMATION ONLY
COMES BACK FOR.
POLICYMAKERS ARE COLLEGE USE IN
THE AGGREGATE SO THERE'S NO
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
THAT HAPPENS THROUGH THAT.
WE HAVE. THIS QUESTION CAME UP
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE COULD DO
AN OPT IN OR OPT OUT PROCESS.
AND I THINK OUR ONLY CONCERN IS
ABOUT THE HOW THAT WOULD
FUNCTION THROUGH THE TWO OFFICES
RIGHT I MEAN I THINK WE WOULD
HAVE TO STEP. GO BACK AND TALK
TO OUR SPECIFIC DATA FOLKS TO
SEE. HOW THAT PROCESS WOULD
WOULD LOOK LIKE?
AND WHAT THAT WOULD ENTAIL IF
IT'S EVEN POSSIBLE. WE DID A
SIMILAR PROCESS FOR THE STUDENT
THE COMMISSION WHERE RIGHT NOW
PLEASE SHARE.
INFORMATION FROM K. TWELVE
DISTRICTS TO STUDENT A
COMMISSION SO WE CAN TRY AND GET
THEM AS MUCH FINANCIAL AID IS
POSSIBLE. BUT NOT PROCESS DID
INCLUDE AN OPT OUT FOR STUDENTS
AND SO WE'RE THINKING MAYBE
THERE'S A MODEL THERE THAT WE TO
FOLLOW BUT WE JUST WEREN'T READY
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION TODAY.
AND AND. I THINK YOU BECAUSE I
ONLY KNOW TO THE CHAIR TO HAVE
HIGHER EDUCATION TO BE LOOKING
OUT FOR STUDENTS AND COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THE NEED FOR US TO HAVE
INFORMATION THAT'S RELIABLE. SO
WE CAN KNOW WHAT WORKS AND WE
CAN WE CAN AND REINFORCE THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT WORK AND SEE WHAT
DOESN'T WORK ABOUT OTHERS AND
HOW WE CAN HELP. ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO CRITICAL EDUCATION
THAT REALLY ANYTHING GOVERNMENT
DOES I'M I I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL THIS TIME MAYBE BY THE TIME
YOU SAW HER EDUCATIONAL. HOW
THIS I JUST CAN'T SAY ENOUGH
HOW WE SHOULD NOT BE
PERPETUATING POOR USE OF FULL SO
SECURITY NEVER THAT BART STATE
HAS NO BUSINESS DOING THAT
ANYMORE?
AND.
ONCE YOU GET DOWN THAT PATH YOU
END UP WITH TECHNOLOGY THAT
WON'T CHANGE.
I REWRITING CODE THAT CAN'T BE
DONE UNLESS YOU SPEND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS DOING IT.
AND WE END UP PATCHWAY IN A
PROBLEM SO I HOPE I STRONGLY
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER.
I'M NOT USING FULL SO SECURITY
NUMBERS
I THINK IT MIGHT HELP ET DE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE. PRESSURE ON
THEM TO GET IT RIGHT.
A AND ALTERNATIVELY PERHAPS ALSO
AT THE SAME TIME YOU MAY NOT GET
THE SAME QUALITY OF DATA BUT
ALLOW PEOPLE TO DECIDE WHEN
THEY'RE SO SECURING MEMBERS ARE
GIVEN WHAT THEY'RE USED FOR EVEN
IF IT'S. NOT DISAGGREGATED.
BUT WITH GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
CHARITABLE HAVE A CHANCE TO WORK
ON AGAIN IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
I'VE I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
ANSWERS.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE. OF ALONGSIDE SO WAS
I. I TO HAVE A CONCERN OVER THE
SECURITY OF THIS I'M I'M GONNA
VOTE YET I QUIT TODAY WITH THE
HOPES THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT WE.
SOME MEMBER BREAK BAKER BROUGHT
UP.
BECAUSE I AM ABLE PROPONENT OF
CT AND I THINK THE DATA IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND FOR OF JOBS GOING
FORWARD WHAT WE NEED IN THE
COMMUNICATIVE. AND.
SO I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE THIS CONSIDERATION.
AS IT MOVES ON TO THE COMMITTEE
HOPEFULLY.
I THINK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
I MISSED MEDINA WAS A CLOSE UP
WELL WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DIALOGUE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK THIS MEDINA WE HAVE A
MOTION FIRST FROM.
NIZAGARA CURRY AND A SECOND
FROM MISTER DALY THAT.
A MAGICALLY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FONG FONG AYE.
FONG NOT VOTING.
AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY AYE
BAKER.
BAKER NO BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER NOW MATHIS.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
THE FOR ITS YOU WILL KEEP THE
ROLE.
OTHER SIR ACOSTA LEAVE YOUR NEXT
THING YOU'LL BE PRESENTING A TO
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
BUT THE GLASSES
STAYS.
THANK YOU BOB.
THEY SHARE MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE IS A SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES THE PERSONALIZATION.
OF GOLD STAR FAMILY LICENSE
PLATES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN
CALIFORNIA'S ISSUED UPON REQUEST
A SPECIALIZED. LICENSE PLATE FOR
QUALIFIED GOLD STAR FAMILY
MEMBERS
THESE IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS
NEEDS OUR IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE LOST A LOVED
ONE IN THE LINE OF DUTY WHILE
SERVING TO PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
WHEN CALIFORNIAN ACT OF THE GOLD
STAR FAMILY LICENSE PLATE
PROGRAM A JOINT FORTY FIVE OTHER
STATES IN AN EFFORT TO HELP
MORNING FAMILIES MEMORIALIZE
THEIR FALLEN HEROES. HOWEVER
THESE LICENSE PLATES ARE ONLY
ISSUED IN A SEQUENTIAL SERIES IN
CALIFORNIA UNLIKE MANY STATES.
RESTRICTING THIS BUT SPECIAL
RECOGNITION OF SACRIFICE IN
HONOR TO A SEQUENTIAL SERIES IS
NOT ONLY ARBITRARY. IT IS
CONTRARY TO THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH AUTHORIZES
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATES TO BE
PERSONALIZED BY THE OWNER OF THE
VEHICLE.
OUR HAS MOST OF YOUR WHERE ARE.
I MY SON ARMY SPECIALIST A RUDY
ACOSTA WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD
WHEN HE WAS KILLED IN SOUTHERN
AFGHANISTAN.
AFTER SERVING AS A MEDIC FOR
NINE MONTHS HE WAS JUST SIX
WEEKS AWAY FROM FINISHING HIS
TOUR OF DUTY. WITH HOPES OF
COMING BACK BECOMING SURGEON.
AND I APPRECIATE CALIFORNIA HAS
A SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATE UP
PROGRAM THAT I CAN USE TO ON A
RUDY.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
PERSONALIZE THAT RECOGNITION
OF MY SON.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY PATTY
SCHUMACHER A FELLOW GOLD STAR
FAMILY MEMBER AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK
FEAR I FELT.
MY NAME IS PATTY SCHUMACHER.
I AM THE PROUD GOLD STARTED.
MOTHER OF LANCE CORPORAL VICTOR
DO.
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
MY SON WAS KILLED ON OCTOBER
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TEN AND
SAYING AND IN THE HELMAND
PROVINCE OF AFGHANISTAN.
HE WAS TWENTY YEARS OLD NEWLY
ENGAGED AND ON ITS FIRST
DEPLOYMENT.
IN FACT IN THE EVENT THAT TOOK
OF LIFE WAS ACTUALLY HIS FIRST
MISSION OUTSIDE THE WIRE.
THE SAFE ZONE OF ITS FORWARD
OPERATING BASE.
HE HAD JUST LEFT THE UNITED
STATES A MERE EIGHTEEN DAYS
PRIOR.
MY SON DECIDED TO SERVICE
COUNTRY AT A YOUNG AGE THE
ATTACKS ON NINE ELEVEN
SOLIDIFIED THAT EVEN AT THAT
TENDER AGE.
OF ELEVEN.
VICTOR HAD IN HIS HEART TO
PROTECT THIS COUNTRY HIS FAMILY
AT ALL COSTS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE NEVER
SUFFERED ANOTHER ATTACK ON OUR
SOIL.
HE WAS WILLING TO TAKE THAT
FIGHT TO THE ENEMY AND DO
WHATEVER HIS COUNTRY ASKED OF
HIM.
VICTOR WAS AN OATH THREE FIFTY
TWO.
AND ANTI TANK ARMOR MISSILE MEN
IN CHARGE OF OUR JAVELIN. AND
TOLL WEAPON SYSTEMS
HE WAS A SECOND DEGREE BLACK
BELT IN JUJITSU.
VICTOR WAS MY FIRST BORN CHILD.
YES I AM A PROUD MOTHER.
I AM PROUD OF MY SON TO HAVE
CHOSEN A SELFLESS PATH.
STEPPED UP. DO ALL THAT NEEDED
TO BE DONE TO BECOME ONE OF THE
FEW. THE PROUD THE BRAVE.
I AM LEFT WITH JUST MEMORIES AND
PRIDE.
I AM LEFT WITH HEARTACHE IN
TEARS AND WHAT IFS.
I AM LEFT WITH TO NEVER FORGET.
I AM LEFT WITH FINDING WAYS TO
HONOR AND REMEMBER HIS SACRIFICE
TO OUR COUNTRY.
I WAS A NEW GOLD STAR MOTHER.
WHEN OUR FAMILY PLATES WERE
AVAILABLE IN DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND TEN.
IN FACT LESS THAN TWO MONTHS
AFTER VICTOR STAFF. I STOOD ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS AND WITNESS
THE FIRST PLATES BEING HANDED TO
OTHER GOLD STAR FAMILIES.
AS THANKFUL AS I AM FOR THESE
PLATES.
IT STILL LEAVES ME THE INABILITY
TO HONOR MY SON IN A WAY THAT I
SEE APPROPRIATE.
I CANNOT SAY HIS NAME HIS
TITLED.
K. I A.
MY HERO.
MY SON.
OR WHATEVER ALL I OR OTHER GOLD
STAR FAMILIES DEAN IS THEIR WAY
OF HONORING THEIR LOVED ONE.
WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS THREE
NUMBERS?
AND THE DESIGNATED LETTERS OF
AGE YOU WHY.
I WANT YOU KNOW.
I NEED DEBT HAVE LETTERS OF MY
CHOOSING THAT REFLECT MY HERO.
AS OPPOSED TO LETTERS THAT SAY
LOOK.
IT IS OUR WAY OF HONORING AND
RESPECTING THEIR SACRIFICE
IT IS THE LEAST
WE CAN DO TO HONOR THEM.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK MY SON'S NAME.
AND EXPRESS MY DEEPEST DESIRE TO
HONOR HIM IN A FASHION THAT IS
PERSONAL TO HIS FAMILY.
LANCE CORPORAL VICTOR DID. MY
HERO.
HUMAN SERVICES FREELANCE.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
HE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
LIKE TO TEST BY IT IN OPPOSITION
OF WAS HER OPINION ON THE
AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE. ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
MR CUSTOMERS LIKE CLOSE.
I THINK YOUR SHARE MEMBERS SET
UP THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB
TWO ONE THREE FIVE I THINK.
MIGHT
IDEA GUEST HERE.
MISTER MARKER A SAID IT WELCOME
WE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR COSTUME AND WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THIS A CONSENT
ITEM WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE HERO WITNESS AND PROPERTY TO
SAVE. HER SON'S NAME AND PUBLIC.
THAT WITHOUT MISTER BECAUSE I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY. MINUTES OCCURRED PLEASE
CALL.
HOW WE DO HAVE A FIRST FROM
SUMMER BAKER AND SECOND?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER FOR
HOUSEKEEPING PLEASE CULTURAL.
THE MAJESTY PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
HI FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AS
WE ARE CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER
AYE BERMAN.
CHAU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER. HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE THIS AREA IN.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE.
IT HAS TEN WILL LEAVETHE ROLL
PIN AND FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU CAN SO SECRETARY STORY
FEELS.
MR CUSTOMERS GO AHEAD AND ON
CALL YOUR SECOND BILL PLEASE.
THANK WAS CHAIR.
.
ONE.
THE BB THIRTY FIVE I JUST.
THE MOB.
SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO THANK YOU
FOR LINE ME UP TO THE PRESENT AB
THIRTY ONE NINETY FIVE. OTHERS
BILL WOULD STREAM LIKE MORE
STREAMLINED MOTORCYCLE LICENSING
BY REQUIRING THE DMV TO
ELECTRONICALLY EXCEPT.
A COMPLETION OF CERTIFICATES
VICAR CERTIFICATE OF COMPLETION
OF A NOVICE OR INTERMEDIATE
MOTORCYCLE TRAINING COURSE
CURRENTLY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLDS ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE A
THREE DAY NOVICE COURSE. IN
ORDER TO ATTAIN OBTAIN A
MOTORCYCLE LICENSE.
I LAST YEAR OF MY BILL AB ONE
ZERO TWO SEVEN ALSO ALLOWED FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD PASSED AN
INTERMEDIATE CLASS.
TO RECEIVE IT DE L. THREE
EIGHTY NINE WAIVER AS IT'S
CALLED. SO.
CHP CURRENTLY REQUIRES CLASS
OPERATORS WHO PREPARED TO SUBMIT
THIS TICKET MONTHLY XIN
ELECTRONICALLY WITH THE DEAN THE
DOES NOT GET ACCEPT THEM
ELECTRONICALLY.
BY ACCEPTING THE CERTIFICATES
ELECTRONICALLY THE DMB WILL NOT
ONLY STREAMLINED LICENSING
PROCESS WILL ALSO ENSURE THE DMP
RECEIVES ALL PAPERWORK
PROTECTING CONSUMER DATA FROM
BEING MISPLACED OR LOST.
I HAVE WITH ME ARE JAMES OF OUR
JUNIOR ARABS AND SPONSOR A BAIT
OF CALIFORNIA. MISTER SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THINK THE
TIME AND ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
PLEASED EACH NAME HE
REPRESENTED ALL REMIND YOU THAT
THERE IS A SUPPORT POSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE CAME SOME BARS SENIOR
ON BEHALF OF A BETA CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE DEALERS.
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THANKED TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NINE ANY.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR
VOICE OUR OPINION OF THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T
THINK IT.
WE HAVE A FIRST BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ANDYOUR CURRY
AND SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SOON.
MISTER HUSTLE BE SPORTING A
BILL TODAY.
AT THAT TIME I WILL ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH DIEM HE ON
ANY IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES.
THAT THEY MAY HAVE WE HAVE A TO
THAT THANK YOU SIR.
MAPS EVERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
A MACHINIST HE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER
AYE FONG. FONG I AGREE ARE CURRY
AND WE ARE CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON HI
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NEWS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE BILL HAS ELEVEN WHAT YOU TO
ROLE OPEN FOR UPS MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU SCARE
MAKE YOU. MISTER HOLDEN.
YOU BE PRESENTING AB TWENTY
THREE OH FOR.
BUT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING OUR BILL
THIS AFTERNOON TO BEGIN WITH
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AB TWENTY THREE OH FOR ASK FOR A
STUDY TO BE CONDUCTED TO EXAMINE
EXISTING TRANSIT PASS PROGRAMS
BETWEEN SCHOOLS IN TRANSIT
AGENCIES.
A STUDY WILL PROVIDE DEFINITIVE
OVERVIEW.
HAVE THE NUMBER OF PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE. WHERE THERE IS A NEED
AND WHAT ARE THE BEST PRACTICES
FOR THESE PROGRAMS?
PROVIDING VIABLE TRANSIT TO THE
STUDENTS
IT'S THEM OUT OF THEIR CARS AND
ON TO PUBLIC TRANSIT.
EIGHTY NOT JUST THEIR EDUCATION
BUT OUR ENVIRONMENT AS WELL.
I BELIEVE THAT HAVING THIS
INFORMATION AT THE READY WOULD
BE. BENEFICIAL TO THE STATE AND
PRESENT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAM ALREADY IN PLACE AND
WHERE IMPROVEMENT AS NECESSARY
AWARE PROGRAM NEEDS.
TO BE CREATED TO ADDRESS A
CRUCIAL NEED.
AB TWENTY THREE OR FOUR WILL DO
JUST THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU
WITNESSES POOR MISTRAL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WE
REPRESENT PLEASE OUT STEVE ALL
HERE AND HAVE THE CALVET BICYCLE
ENGINES FOR THE BILL. ALSO AND
HAVE THE ON THE COUNTRY'S DISH
COMMISSION DEVON FORMER.
DOUBLING THE BILL ENTERED YOUR
SUPPORT.
PLEASE SAY YOUR NAMES WE
REPRESENT PLEASE JIM LIGHTS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THE FIRST OR SECOND MR MEDINA
AND MISTER DALY RESPECTIVELY.
I ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE CAME MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OR. VOICE
AN OPINION OF THE AUTHORS.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE.
COMMITTEE.
NONE.
IT'S ALWAYS CLOSE THE MISTER
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH US
ON THIS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU MISTER ALL I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
AS WE'VE DISCUSSED IN THE
COMMITTEE BEFORE MANY TRANSIT
AGENCIES HAVE SUCCESSFUL TRANSIT
PASS PROGRAMS.
FOR STUDENTS FROM MANY OTHER
PEOPLE.
I AM WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE
TRANSIT AGENCIES HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PERCENT
INCREASE IN FUNDING. THAT
BECAUSE THAT CAN BE USED TO
EXPAND THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THE FULL
EXTENT OF WHAT IS OUT THERE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS STUDY
REQUIRED BY YOUR BILL.
IS SO IMPORTANT TO GET THE DATA.
BEFORE WE CONSIDER ANY KIND OF A
NEW PROOF PROGRAM.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT TRANSIT
AGENCIES SCHOOLS AND OTHERS ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW.
AND HOW THEIR PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDED IN WHAT GAPS MIGHT STILL
EXIST.
SO WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALLED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FUNG I AND WE
ARE CURRY. AND WE ARE CURRY AYE
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHAU. CHIU AYE DALY. DALY AYE
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA.
I DO NOT AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE BILL IS TWELFTH WILL KEEP
OPEN TRAPS MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR COMING OVER TO EUROPE.
AB.
THIRTY FIFTEEN.
PLEASE PERSONA READING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS UP THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE B.
THIRTY FIFTEEN RETRO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S NEED. FOR A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION OR FREIGHT
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK AND
SUPPLY CHAINS FROM OUR CURRENT
DIESEL BASED TECHNOLOGY. TOWARDS
ZERO AND NEAR ZERO EMISSIONS
FUTURE. THIS WILL BE A COMPLEX
AND EXPENSIVE PROCESS AND NOT
WITHOUT SOME CONTROVERSY. BUT IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE STATE'S
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION IN
CLEAN AIR GOALS THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT A TRANSITION NEEDS TO
OCCUR.
BUT BECAUSE THIS IS COMPLEX AND
EXPENSIVE IT IS IMPERATIVE TO BE
PLANNED. THAT MAY BE IMPLEMENTED
WITH OUR INDUSTRY AND LABOR
PARTNERS AT THE TABLE. AND THAT
WHEN WE INVEST STATE DOLLARS
INTO NEW INFRASTRUCTURE AND NEW
EQUIPMENT THAT WE DO IT WITH A
WELL THOUGHT OUT IN STRATEGIC
PLAN. OTHERWISE YOU RUN THE RISK
OF SETTLING THOSE WHO
ULTIMATELY.
PAID FOR INVESTMENT IN OUR POLL
AND IMPORTS OF CARGO THAT IT
SHIPPED. WITH SIGNIFICANT COSTS
AND JEOPARDIZE THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF OUR PARTS AND I
THINK.
IN PARTICULAR NOW WITH THE
COMPETITION OF PORTS.
IN OTHER STATES OF THIS BECOMES
REALLY BAD CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
I AS YOU ARE AWARE CALIFORNIA'S
PORTS ARE A CRITICAL COMPONENT
COMPONENT OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMY
AND AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
DISTRICT WITH HEAVY INTEREST IN
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS. I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND INVESTMENT IN OUR
PORT GATEWAYS CAN SUPPORT AND
GROW JOBS ALL ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE VALUE OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
THAT WERE EXPORTED TO THE PORT
OF OAKLAND IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TOTAL OVER SIX POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE WE KNOW ALL TOO
WELL THAT INCREASED TRADE
BARRIERS CAN CAUSE REAL HARM.
THIS CAN OCCUR AT THE
INTERNATIONAL LEVEL LIKE WE HAVE
SEEN WITH TERRACE BEING ACTIVELY
DEBATED IN BEIJING AND
WASHINGTON DCSCENERY RIGHT NOW
WHICH THREATENED TO HEAVILY
IMPACT OUR STATE'S FARMERS. AND
AG COMMUNITIES INCREASES IN THE
COST OF TRADE CAN ALSO OCCUR AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AB THIRTY
FIFTEEN WILL HELP TO AVOID THIS.
WE CAN ALL ANTICIPATE THAT WILL
WE WILL HAVE MORE COSTLY PART
INFRASTRUCTURE ANY EQUIPMENT
COSTS BUT WITH GOOD PLANNING AND
LONG TERM INVESTMENTS WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT OUR TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSIONS. WILL HAVE
POSITIVE IMPACTS ON JOBS AND
LIVES IN BOTH RURAL CALIFORNIA
AND IN. COMMUNITIES NEIGHBORING
THE PORTS
WITH ME TODAY IS MY CHECK UP OF
THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIGHT TAKE WITH THE MSA.
AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL ONE AND
I THINK JUST TO THE ACT OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S COMMENTS.
QUICKLY WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE WORK WITH THE
STATE AND PARTNERSHIP ON
INFRASTRUCTURE AN ON AIR QUALITY
ISSUES. WE LIKE TO HAVE THAT.
PARTNERSHIP CONTINUE IN A
FORMAL CAPACITY WITH INCLUSION
OF THE PLANS.
AND A NO MATTER WHAT TECHNICAL
FEASIBILITY COMES TO PASS.
BUT WE DO KNOW FROM OUR
EXPERIENCES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND.
.
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
CAN GET TO ZERO EMISSIONS.
THAT THEIR TO PASS FOR THAT.
ONE IS WHAT'S HAPPENING THEN THE
PORT OF LA AND LONG BEACH WHICH
IS INVESTMENT.
AND.
ADVANCEMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
THE MOST MODERN EQUIPMENT WE
HAVE.
THE OTHER ONE IS THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. AND THAT'S WE HAD OUR
HARPER TERMINAL GO BANKRUPT THAT
IS THE WRONG TYPE OF ZERO
EMISSIONS TERMINAL.
THE NO WANTS TO SAY AND SO WE'D
LIKE TO SEE LONG TERM PLANNING
SO WE CAN FACILITATE THE
INVESTMENT WE NEED TO TRANSITION
PROPERLY.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME HE
REPRESENT PLEASE. AIDAN MEDI UP
YOU KNOW SUFFER LA. A WEIRD
SPORT OF THE BILL.
WE ARE EXPERIMENTING RIGHT NOW
WITH THE ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR OUR YARD EQUIPMENT THAT A
COUPLE OF OUR LARGEST YARDS
WE'VE INSTALLED CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND.
PROTESTING OUR TRUCKS WE THINK
THE TIMING OF THIS MEASURE TO
STUDY IS A PERFECT SO. SWIFT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC OF ELECT TEST FIND
SPORTING AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR VOICE HER OPINION
OF THE AUTHORS.
SING ON QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
THIS COMPANY ARE WHICH LIKE
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS
BILL TODAY.
IN ORDER SUPPORT THE FREIGHT
INDUSTRY WE MUST FIRST GET THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO MAKE WISE
INVESTMENTS AND PROMOTE THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE REGULATIONS. WHEN
YOU STEPPED UP THERE YOU HAD ME
AT HELLO.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION ANDERS
INDUSTRY TO WORK WITH THE
CORRESPONDING SEAT AGENCIES GET
THE MOST ROBUST INFORMATION SO
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT THE PORTS
WHICH ARE A THIRD. OF OUR
ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE JOBS THAT IT WILL AND
DOES SUPPORT.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY.
VERY ENTHUSIASTIC.
KLAY SO LINKLETTER SPEAKER MATH.
MADAM SECRETARY OF MY.
SO ENTHUSIASTIC.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FUNG I AGREE I
CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY AYE BAKER
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
AS ARYAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
YOU HAVE TWELVE BELIEVE RULE OUT
OPEN TRAPS MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER DALY.
AB THIRTY TWO WILL ONE PLEASE.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
THIS MEASURE ALLOWS TRANSIT
AGENCIES
IN OUR STATE TO RETAIN THE
ABILITY TO UTILIZE IN CENTER
FUNDING.
AS THE INTRODUCE MORE ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT BUSES.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS TO
ACHIEVE A ZERO EMISSION TRANSIT
SYSTEM
STATE WIDE. BY THE YEAR TWENTY
FORTY.
THIS IS A LOT OF ALL GOAL IT HAS
WIDESPREAD WIDESPREAD SUPPORT.
AND IT'LL HELP CALIFORNIA MEET
ITS AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE TARGETS.
BUT WITH JUST
SWIFT TRANSITION.
WELCOME ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES ON TRANSIT AGENCIES
WHO ALREADY OPERATE ON SMALL
MARGINS.
PRESSURES TO INCREASE BUS FARES.
THE PRICE FOR A ZERO EMISSION
BUS CAN BE THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
APPROXIMATELY MORE EXPENSIVE
THEN ITS TRADITIONAL
COUNTERPART.
AS OF A FEW MONTHS AGO TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN OUR STATE HAD ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN ZERO EMISSION
BUSES IN OPERATION. WITH AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED FORTY
ON ORDER.
ALL OF THESE PURCHASES ALL OF
THESE WERE PURCHASED WITH THE
HELP OF INCENTIVE FUNDING I
REPEAT ALL OF THEM WERE
PURCHASED WITH THE HELP OF SOME
TYPE OF INCENTIVE FOR.
ON TOP OF THE UP FRONT COST
PRESSURES TO PURCHASE THESE MORE
EXPENSIVE BUSES TRANSIT AGENCIES
MUST ALSO FUNDING CREATE A
COMPLETELY NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF A
ZERO EMISSION FLEA.
IT'S VITAL THAT FUNDING REMAIN
AVAILABLE IN ORDER FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO SET.
EXCESSIVELY COMPLY WITH
RAPID.
TRANSITION REGULATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY IS MICHAEL
PAYMENTS ALL REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
MODERATE TOP REPRESENTING THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION.
AUTHORITY.
AND RICK CHROMOSPHERE WITH THE
COUNTY CONNECTION.
THIS BILL SPONSOR IS THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU MISTER DALY AND THANK
YOU FOR BRING YOUR POSSE.
.
WE WILL HAVE A FOR SPEAKER
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND.
WE REPRESENT PLEASE.
SURE THING MISTER CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL HIMSELF
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY NOTED THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD IS IN
THE PROCESS OF PROMULGATING A
REGULATION.
THAT WOULD TRANSITION
CALIFORNIAS TRANSIT FLEET TO ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT ZERO EMISSION BY
TWENTY FORTY.
AT THE HEART OF THIS REGULATION
IS A PURCHASE MANDATE.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE EVERY
TRANSIT AGENCY THE STATE.
BEGINNING SOMETIME AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY TO PURCHASE ZERO EMISSION
BUSES AS PART OF THEIR NECKS
PROCUREMENTS.
WHEN THIS PURCHASE MANDATE GOES
INTO A FACT.
ARB WILL DISALLOW PUBLIC
TRANSACTIONS HE'S A MEAT ONLY
THE BASELINE PURCHASE
REQUIREMENTS FROM ACCESSING
INCENTIVE FUNDING ALREADY
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
TO SUPPORT ZERO MISSION BUS
DEPLOYMENT.
YOUR BE ARGUES THAT THIS
APPROACH IS NECESSARY AND
BECAUSE OF ELECTED BOARD POLICY
THAT PROHIBITS THE USE OF
INCENTIVE FUNDING. TO BE
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AYE AND
APPROPRIATE NOT TO ENCOURAGE
ZERO MISSION BUS DEPLOYMENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT IS
REQUIRED BY THE REGULATIONS.
SOME SUPPORTERS OF YOUR BEES
APPROACH OF TAKEN THAT.
CONSISTENT BUT MORE STRIDENT
POSITION.
ARGUING THAT IN MEETING
REGULATORY OBLIGATIONS THE
POLLUTER SHOULD PAY.
I IN DOING SO THE SUPPORTERS OF
TAKING A PRINCIPLE CALMLY APPLY
TO OTHER REGULATED ENTITIES.
THAT POLLUTE AS A CREE PROFIT
AND APPLIED IT TO A RESOURCE
CONSTRAINED PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
SEE.
THAT ALREADY REDUCE EMISSIONS
BY TAKING CARS OFF THE ROAD.
I KNOW MATTER JUST.
THE JUSTIFICATION ARE MEMBERS
OF WRONGLY AGREEING THAT
LIMITING ACCESS TO ENSIGN
FUNDING FOR ZERO MISSION BUS
DEPLOYMENT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
I WITHOUT ACCESS JONES AND
FUNDING THAT IS IF PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES HAVE TO BEAR
THE FULL COST OF THIS TRANSITION
TO ZERO EMISSION BUSES. THEY
HAVE TO PULL RESOURCES AWAY FROM
OTHER VALUABLE USES SUCH A STATE
OF GOOD REPAIR. DAILY SERVICE
AYE AND OTHERWISE UNDERMINE THE
VIABILITY PUBLIC TRANSIT.
WE ASK FOR GOD OF THANK YOU FOR
THE DISSERTATION. ON NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE ATOP
ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. AND.
WE ARE IN VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
AS OUTLINED AIR BE IS
PROMULGATING REGULATIONS AND WE
ARE WE'RE APPRECIATIVE OF THESE
THESE RAGS THERE ARE. OTHER BOLD
THEIR INNOVATIVE.
THEY ARE AGGRESSIVE.
BUT THEY COME WITH A REAL A
REAL PRICE TAG AND BOB FOR
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WHAT WE KNOW AS WE'VE.
WE'VE GONE BACK AND WE'VE
CRUNCHED THE NUMBERS AND WE.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A A RP
BUT BUT THE NUMBERS ARE.
PARTICULARLY STARK FOR US.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED A ACOSTA FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO COMPLY WITH THIS WITH
THIS REGULATION AND JUST TO PUT
IT IN CONTEXT.
ARE ARE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE BUDGET FOR. THE
ENTIRE AYE COUNTIES A TRANSIT
SYSTEM IS TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THIS WOULD
WIPE OUT TWO YEARS OF FUNDING
THAT WE. ARE THAT WE USE TO I
TRIED IMPORTANT TRANSIT
SERVICES.
TO TOURISTS ARE CITIZENS.
I'M WE THINK THIS IS ONE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WHAT IT WILL
DO IS IT'LL HELP.
PROVIDE INNOVATION AND.
HOPEFULLY GET THAT COST LOWER
AS WE ARE ONTINUE TO INNOVATE
AND PROVIDE MORE COST EFFECTIVE
MEANS TO MEET THIS REGULATION.
I'M NOT STILL GOING TO BE VERY
VERY COSTLY FOR AGENCIES.
WE.
WE WE HAVE ESTIMATED THAT WE
THINK OF REGULATION LIKE THIS
COULD COST.
IN TERMS OF TRANSIT SERVICE A
TWENTY TWO PERCENT REDUCTION IN
SERVICE.
ARE WE.
SERVE PRIMARILY A LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY O.
ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF OUR.
OF OUR BUS RIDERS ARE FROM
HOUSEHOLDS THAT EARN LESS THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SEWER A
PROPOSAL.
THAT COULD CUT SERVICE COULD
HAVE A VERY REAL IMPACT SO WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THIS
THOUGHTFUL BILL THAT WILL GET US
ON THE ROAD TO MAKING. UP A
BALANCED.
AND APPROPRIATE.
REGULATORY SCHEME.
AT ARB THINK YOU VERY MUCH
SO WE'VE HAD TO SPEAKERS HAVE
BEEN VERY PASSIONATE. AND WHAT I
WANT IT TO IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
MARRYING THEIR.
PLEASE TAKE UNTIL.
.
MISTER DALY HAD ME AT HELLO
ALSO.
SPECIAL ON THIS THIS ISSUE WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT PAYER ABUSE
DOING A TO THE TRANSIT INDUSTRY
SO IF YOU COULD.
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF WITH
OTHER WITNESSES THAT HAVE TO.
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OUT BE BRIEF ON REC
RAMMUS YOUR GENERAL MANAGER
COUNTY CONNECTIONS CENTRAL
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT AUTHORITY
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
AT YOUR FRAZIER ARRAIGNED CANDY
WITH CLEAN ENERGY. AND ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF OUR TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS OF BY RG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND.
EAGLE COALITION HOW WE OUGHT TO
BE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AND.
I THINK THE THE AUTHOR INVOLVED
RESPECT IN OUR A SUPPORTERS AND
MADE THE CASE.
VERY WELL IF THIS IS GONNA
REQUIRE A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THIS IS
GONNA SQUEEZE OUT THE EXISTING.
PROJECTS AND.
AND DEATH FUNDS FOR THOSE
ALREADY IN THIS PROGRAM.
AND THE OTHER RIGHT NOW PROGRAM
IS TECH NEWS SHOW FOR ZERO AND
NEAR ZERO BYTES.
IT'S THE ULTIMATE ULTIMATELY
COME DOWN TO AIR BE MAKING THE
DECISIONS WITH THEIR FUNDING
PLAN AND THERE COULD BE PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS AND WITH THIS
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF FUNDING NEEDED
IT'S GONNA SQUEEZE OUT.
THOSE THAT ARE IT NEEDED TO
ALREADY.
ALSO MENTION TO YOU THAT.
HOW BUSINESS CERTAINTY IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN A STEADY STREAM OF
FUNDS THAT ARE KNOWN AND?
?
AT IT WITH A GREAT AMOUNT TIME
THAT OUT IN FRONT AND I WERE
CONCERNED THAT THAT THAT WILL
BE.
AT AN ISSUE AS WELL AS THE SITE
GOES FOR SO WE DO RESPECTFULLY
WHERE I REQUEST ID CONCERT SOME
CONSIDERATION OF THE OTHER
PROJECTS THAT THIS WILL BE
SQUEEZED OUT FOR THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
DECISION A WE REPRESENT MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JOSHUA SHOP FOR
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
THEIR BIG BLUE BUS TRANSIT
OPERATION IN SUPPORT YOU.
STEVE WELCOME AT THE CENTER FOR
TRANSLATION ENVIRONMENT ALSO
SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
VINCENT WHERE MUCH OF WHAT THE
WHITENING GRIP ON THAT THE PYD
MOTORS A CALIFORNIA BASED
MANUFACTURER BETTER LOGIC TRUCKS
AND BUSES IN SUPPORT.
MOVE THE BILL.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TALK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
MANY MAKE ROOM PLEASE FOR ONE
THIRD OF ONE WITNESS PLACE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WHO
REPRESENT PLEASE.
KATHY CATHERINE PHILLIPS WITH
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS INTEREST IN ZERO EMISSION
BUSES WE HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING
ZERO EMISSION BUSES FOR A LONG
TIME. I WANT TO CORRECT A FEW
THINGS THAT SHOWED UP IN THE AN
OUNCE THIS AND ALSO IN THE
TESTIMONY WE JUST HEARD. THERE
IS NO DRAFT REGULATION OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW. WHAT HAS BEEN
CIRCULATED IS ON VARIOUS
OCCASIONS ARE?
WHITE PAPERS.
AND THERE'S THE MOST RECENT
WHITE PAPER INDICATES รณ
THERE'S A THREE PAGER THAT CAME
OUT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
INDICATES THAT THE.
AGENCY HAS BEEN LISTENING TO
THE TRANSIT AGENCIES AS THEY
HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO THE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS.
AND ARE PREPARED TO.
CHANGE SOME OF THE ELEMENTS.
OF THEIR PROPOSAL SO THAT.
THE THE THE START DATE OF THE
REGULATION WON'T BE AS SOON AS
HAS BEEN IN THE MOST RECENT ONE.
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT'S WHAT
ARE YOU KNOW HAVE YOU EVER HAD
THAT EXPERIENCE WHERE. YOU THINK
SOMETHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND
THEN FIFTEEN YEARS LATER YOUR
WORST FEAR COMES TRUE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M HEARING TODAY
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS WE
WORRIED ABOUT WHEN WE STARTED
GROUP. ENVIRONMENTALISTS STARTED
SUPPORTING INCENTIVES FOR EARLY.
ADOPTION OF TECHNOLOGIES AND
PUBLIC MONEY GOING INTO EARLY
ADOPTION OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THIS WAS THAT WE WOULD
INCREASINGLY SEE THE REGULATED
INDUSTRY COMING IN AND SAYING.
YOU SHOULDN'T ADOPT ANY
REGULATION UNLESS YOU HAVE
PUBLIC MONEY TO PUT UP FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT REGULATION.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SEE HAPPENING
HERE THE KINDS OF TESTIMONY WE
HEARD HERE TODAY IS VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT YOU HEAR. INCREASINGLY
OVER AT THE REGULATORY AT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
REGULATIONS ARE COMING UP.
SO OF FIRST OF ALL THIS IS A
PREMATURE BILL THE REGULATION
STILL HASN'T EVEN COME OUT IN
DRAFT FORM.
SECONDLY. YOU KNOW ASPECTS OF
THE BILL ARE FINE THE ONE THING
THAT WE WOULD ASK IS THAT THE.
PHRASE THAT WOULD ALLOW
COMPLIANCE THIS MONEY TO BE USED
FOR COMPLIANCE AS OPPOSED TO
EARLY.
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN EARLY
COMPLIANCE.
BE STRICKEN. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
VOICE OUR OPINION WHO. OF HIS
BILL SING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR.
I'M GONNA VOTE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BUT I'M WANT TO TAKE
A LOOK OF MORE AT SOME OF THE.
METRICS AND THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE SMALLER AGENCIES IN
THE LARGER AGENCIES AND HOW
THEY'RE FUNDING SOURCES COME
FROM AS WELL. AND MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS NOT OVERLY BROAD AND IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO.
TARGETING EVERYONE ONE MAYBE IT
SHOULD BE TARGETING THE AGENCIES
THAT REALLY ARE UNABLE TO TURN.
AROUND.
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS.
THAT IS AN EXCELLENT POINT.
SOME OF IT SOMEBODY AGENCIES
HAVE LOCAL.
REVENUES OTHERS DON'T.
.
THE FAREBOX RECOVERY.
AND DYNAMIC IN EACH AGENCY IS
DIFFERENT AND.
.
I WAS A BOARD MEMBER.
AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY FOR
YEARS AND IT'S SO. THERE
PRESSURES TO RAISE THE FARE BOX.
RECOVERY BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING
NO.
EXPENSES AND RIDERSHIP IS AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE TO ME THE REAL
GOAL OF THESE TRANSIT AGENCIES
IS TO CARRY AS MANY FOLKS AS
POSSIBLE.
AND.
SO I THINK WE ALL HAVE THE SAME
GOAL HERE IS JUST HOW WE GET
THERE WHAT ARE THE METRICS WHAT
IS THE TIMING THE TIMING
QUESTION IS IMPORTANT. SO WHY
APPRECIATE QUESTIONS AND I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY.
SO. WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME OF
THE.
.
REGULATORY AGENCIES OUT THERE.
SOMETIMES QUEST TO DO GOOD.
DOES HARM.
AND.
.
I WOULD HATE HOPE IT'S NOT A
VEILED ACTION TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES BY DECIMATING THE ABILITY
FOR TRANSIT SYSTEMS TO OPERATE.
AND.
ADDS CAPACITY RATHER THAN TAKE
AWAY FROM OF THE CAPACITY I WISH
A OR B. WOULD HAVE BEEN HERE
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO
THIS.
I GUESS IS HERE CLICK HERE
REPRESENTING A RB.
.
NO I'M SORRY SIR WE'RE ONLY
REPRESENTING SIERRA CLUB OR YOU
MENTIONED IT WAS PREMATURE BILL
LIST WELL I DO THINK IT'S A
PREMATURE BILL THAT THAT'S A
SIERRA CLUB POSITION. OKAY THANK
YOU PROOF CLARIFYING THAT.
BUT WILL THANK IS A PREEMPTIVE
BILL.
BECAUSE HALF THE TIME WHEN
WHITE PAPERS OR.
THOUGHTS COME OUT OF AN AGENCY
THEY BECOME.
NOW REGULATION WITHOUT MUCH
THOUGHT PROCESS.
SO WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND I REALLY DO THINK.
ALLOWING ACCESS TO INCENTIVES.
.
REDUCES THE NEEDS FOR CUTTING WE
ARE CURRY.
AND WE ARE CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. SHOW.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE HARPER.
MATHIS.
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I
WE DOES TEND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
CONTRACTS MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THINKING.
SOME REMEMBER CREEL.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN.
ALL
.
SEE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
Q..
I GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE M. HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTEEN.
A BILL THAT WOULD HELP MAXIMIZE
SAFE AND CONVENIENT ACCESS FOR
BICYCLES AND PEDESTRIANS TO
CALIFORNIA PARKS. CALIFORNIA'S
HOME TO NUMEROUS STATE AND LOCAL
PARKS THAT OFFER FUND AN
ENRICHING EXPERIENCE TO THOSE
WHO MAKE USE OF THEM. ACCESS TO
THESE PARKS HAS MANY UPSIDES
INCLUDING ENCOURAGING PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY IN PROMOTING HEALTH AND
MENTAL WELLNESS.
IN SOME CASES BEAST PICTURESQUE
PARKS ARE WITHIN SIGHT OF MANY
RESIDENTS BUT JUST OUT OF REACH.
THESE PARKS CAN HAVE ACCESS
ISSUES ARE PHYSICAL BARRIERS
NEAR THEM.
SUCH AS ROADWAYS ARE UNSAFE
TERRAIN THAT MAKE IT HAZARDOUS
FOR PEOPLE TO ENSURE THEM ON
FOOT OR RIDING BIKES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION OR CALTRANS IS
CHARGED WITH COORDINATING IN
DEVELOPING TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND POLICY HOWEVER.
ISSUES RELATING TO SAVE PARK
ACCESS ARE NOT OFTEN CONSIDER
WHEN PLANNING. AND POLICY MAKING
FOR TRANSPORTATION.
PROJECTS.
TRUST ISSUE PROJECTS.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN WILL
MANDATE THAT CALTRANS
COLLABORATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION AND
OTHER PUBLIC ENTITIES. TO
FACILITATE GREATER COMMUNICATION
AND COORDINATION THAT EMPHASIZES
THESE CONCERNS OF SAFE
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE ACCESS TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THIS COOPERATION WILL HELP CLEAR
THE WAY FOR MORE OF OUR
RESIDENTS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE MAGNIFICENT. PARKS WITHIN
OUR STATE AND CONSEQUENTLY
ENCOURAGING PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
PROMOTING HEALTH AND MENTAL
ILLNESS.
NO ONE SHOULD BE DENIED ACCESS
TO SAFE FUN PARKS AND THOSE
EXPERIENCES. OUR PARKS OUR
PRECIOUS RESOURCES FOR OUR STATE
AND OUR RESIDENTS. AND WE MUST
DO ALL WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE CAN ENJOY THEM SUCH AS
THIS BEAUTIFUL.
BLACK AND WHITE PHOTOGRAPH THAT
WE HAVE IN THIS A COMMITTEE
ROOM.
AND WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY ARE
A FELLOW ADDED ON THOUGH OF
LATINO OUTDOORS AND ONE A COMING
DOWN ALL OF THE OUT OF WORK OUT
OF ON CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE TEACH NAMELY REPRESENT
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON WAS CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS OFTEN
EITHER ALONE THOUGH I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE YOU KNOW WHAT
DOORS TODAY IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
TWO SIX ONE FIVE. BUT YOU KNOW
DOORS IS UNIQUE AND LET YOU KNOW
LET ORGANIZATION.
WORKING TO CREATE A NATIONAL
COMMUNITY OF LEADERS IN
CONSERVATION AND OUTDOOR
EDUCATION.
IN THE STATE AND AND IN THE
COUNTRY. AS PART OF THIS WORK
WERE FOCUSED ON EXPANDING
AMPLIFYING LOOKING EXPERIENCE IN
THE OUTDOORS.
BY PROVIDING LEADERSHIP
MENTORSHIP AND PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO LEADERS THROUGHOUT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND DOING
THIS WORK IN PARKS AND OTHER
PUBLIC LAND SPEED.
SUFFER IF YOU WANT DOORS
OUTINGS INCLUDE TAKING STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES ON.
HIKING AND BACKPACKING รณ
WHICH INCLUDE.
COMPONENTS OF INTERPRETATION
AND AFTER EDUCATION.
TYPICALLY JUST INVOLVE
CORDONING VEHICULAR
TRANSPORTATION YOU KNOW GETTING
FOLKS INTO A CARAVAN AND GOING
OUT TO THESE DIFFERENT PLACES.
BUT OFTENTIMES WE DO ENCOURAGE.
IF POSSIBLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BEING ABLE TO ENCOURAGE THE
PARTICIPANTS TO TO WALK OR BIKE
TO THE. THE PARKING QUESTION.
.
SO GOING THROUGH EMPHASIZING
THIS YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE.
NOT ONLY A FIRST TIME
EXPERIENCE FOR A LOT OF THE IN
THE PARTICIPANTS BUT.
ENCOURAGING A REPEAT ACTION.
GIVEN THE PROXIMITY TO A LOT OF
THESE RESIDENCES.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE MANY
EXAMPLES WHERE EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
MAKES THIS REALLY DIFFICULT.
.
SO MAKING ACCESS TO STATE
REGIONAL LOCAL PARKS AND PUBLIC
LANDS ON FOOT OR BY BICYCLE.
IS A CORPORATE ALREADY FOR
NOTHING WHAT DOORS.
ESPECIALLY FOR COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS THAT LIVE.
SOMETIMES WITHIN A HUNDRED FEET
OF A PARK BUTTON THERE JUST ON
THE WRONG SIDE OF A HIGHWAY OR
FREEWAY.
AND FOR THE REASONS I OUTLINED
BY SOME REPEAL LATINO DOORS THAT
IS A REALLY STRONG SUPPORTER OF
AB TWO SIX ONE FIVE.
AND AND THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING US A TIME
PRESENT AND.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN MY BOOK
NEXT BAKER PLEASE STATIONING YOU
REPRESENT PLEASE.
QUALIFY ME NOT A WITH OUT OF ON
CALIFORNIA I AM THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY FOR.
FRAUD ONE CALIFORNIAN WHERE
HERE IS STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN OTTAWA
CALIFORNIA'S A CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION.
DEDICATED TO PROMOTING AND
PURPOSE.
AND PROTECTING IMPORTANT BIRD
HABITAT AND CONNECTING PEOPLE TO
NATURE WE DO PROGRAMMING ON
SEVERAL DIFFERENT FRONTS AROUND
THE STATE INCLUDING EDUCATIONAL
CENTERS.
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING
RICHARDSON BAY NORTHEAST LESTAT
OUTLOOK NORTHEAST LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE ALSO HAVE A NETWORK OF.
OVER FORTY WORKERS FORTY NINE
LOCAL CHAPTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WHO PROVIDE MONTHLY
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS ABOUT BIRDS
AND NATURE WEEKLY TRIPS ARE TOO
IMPORTANT BIRD AREAS INCLUDING
TO STATE LOCAL REGIONAL PARKS
ANOTHER UNIQUE? NATURAL AREAS
SPECIFICALLY.
WE OPERATE OWNED AND OPERATED
THE BET DEPP'S PARK CENTER
NORTHEAST LOS ANGELES.
WHOSE MISSION IS TO INSPIRE
PEOPLE TO EXPERIENCE
UNDERSTANDING CARE FOR THE. THE
LOCAL NATURAL WORLD ON THE
NATURAL NATURE BASED EDUCATION
AND EX AND COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
ATTACK DEPTHS PARK. ARE DESIGNED
TO ENGAGE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
IN THE OUTDOOR WORLD AND GIVE
THEM A PERSONAL STAKE IN ITS UP
PROTECTION BY MAKING
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. RELEVANT
TO THEIR LIVES THE CENTER WHICH
IS SURROUNDED PREDOMINATELY BY A
LATINO NEIGHBORHOODS IS A
UNIQUE.
NOW GATHERING PLACE IN DYNAMIC
FOCAL POINT FOR OUT THE
RECREATION. ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION CONSERVATION ACTION
UNFORTUNATELY ACCESS TO OUR
CENTER CAN BE CHALLENGING AT
TIMES.
WELL THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY WHO INTERACT
WITH OUR CENTER IN ITS
PROGRAMMING. THE EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
MAKES THE PEDESTRIAN. AND AND BY
OF.
TRAFFIC AXIS DIFFICULT TO OUR
CENTER AND THIS BILL.
.
YEAH ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE IN
THOSE CHALLENGES AND FOR THOSE
REASONS ARE AMONG CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
TWENTY AB TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN
AND VERY.
THANKFUL FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AND HER LEADERSHIP AND TAKING
OF ISSUE.
.
TAKING ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
AFTER AFTER STEVE ALL HERE ON
THE OF THE CALVARY FAISAL
COALITION ALSO SPORTED A BILL
MERGERS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME HERE
REPRESENTING PLEASE HANNAH
TILLMAN ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND SUPPORT.
DOMINIC OFTEN I'LL BE OUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
CATHERINE PHILLIPS FOR SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BUILD.
WE LORD WHO YET.
SO HOPE.
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF
HOME.
HOW? MANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR
VOICE OUR OPINION ON THE OTHERS
BILL.
SAME NIGHT QUESTIONS A.
COULD THE COMMITTEE OF THE
AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
SO MEMORIES LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE OFFERS FROM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER A YEAR CURRY AND
SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN.
THINK WAS MISTER BERMAN.
.
MS KICKED CREEL. THANK YOU FOR
THIS BILL.
ENSURING SAFE ACCESS TO OUR
PARKS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND CALTRANS SHOULD BE INVOLVED
IN MAKING SURE THAT HAPPENS WHEN
IT'S AB UP GLOBAL.
MY PREVIOUS BILL AB FIVE
THIRTEEN CREATES FUNDING.
FOR ACCESS PROJECTS TO PARK
SYMBOLIC WAYS AND HOPEFULLY YOU.
EGGMAN ASSIST YOU IN YOUR
EFFORTS WITH THE BE TWENTY SIX
FIFTEEN.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A LOT OF
MONEY IN THAT ACCOUNT FROM CAO
RECYCLE. THAT MAKES VERY EXCITED
GO GET IT.
WITH THE HELP OF THE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS DE PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE FRAZIER AYE
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AND WE
ARE CURRY. AND WE ARE CURRY AYE
HE BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I HATE YOU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON CROWD GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
I'D NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THERE'S TWELVE WILL KEEP THE
RULE OPEN FOR THE FUNDING FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THEY CAN GET CONGRATULATIONS
THINKING IS GOING THROUGH.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
GO FORWARD WITH CONSENT
CALENDAR.
FIRST AND SECOND BY MISTER
GIPSON SECOND BY MISTER DALY
THANK YOU.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AND WE
ARE CURRY. AND WE ARE CURRY AYE
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN AND
BERMAN AYE EACH TO.
DAILY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
THAT'S ARYAN. NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
WAS.
THAT HAS TWELVE NEW LEADER. JUST
GO THROUGH THE.
LISTA CALLS ON THE REMAINDER OF
THE.
.
OF THE OUTCOMES COMMITTEE.
THAT'S OKAY PROCEED.
FINALLY I AM TO AB NINETEEN OH
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS TO
READ IT TOO FRAZIER.
BERMAN.
FILE ITEM TO AB NINETEEN OH
SEVEN.
BERMAN NOT VOTING.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
MATHIS.
MATHIS INEZ ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
YES IT IS.
NAZARIAN AYE. O'DONNELL.
THE FINAL VOTE.
FIVE TO TWO. WHO CLOSE WRONG
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE SECOND?
I DON'T.
FILE ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO ZERO AG WE ARE CURRY.
AND WE ARE CURRY AYE A BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL AYE.
MISTER CHAIR FINAL VOTE TENSES
ERA WAS A LAWYER IN ABSTENTION
ON THAT ONE.
YES SIR YOU I LIKE TO BE A S. ON
THAT DAILY THAT CHANGE NOT
VOTING TO AYE FINAL VOTE ELEVEN
TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FOR.
AB TWO ZERO FIVE EIGHT THE
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO
FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
I'M SORRY.
O'DONNELL I.
FINAL VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY TWO ONE
THREE FIVE THE CURRENT VOTERS
TEND TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I FIND OVER THIRTEEN TO
ZERO.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
OH FOR THE CURRENT VOTERS TWELVE
TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I MATHIS.
VIOLATE HIM SEVEN AB TWENTY
THREES.
MATHIS AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTEEN THE CURRENT VOTERS
TWELVE TO ZERO CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FINAL VOTE TWELVE TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWO SIX SIX SIX
THE CURRENT VOTERS FORTY TWO
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I AM BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
FIND OTHER NINE TO TWO.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB THREE ZERO
ONE FIVE THE CURRENT VOTERS
TWELVE TO ZERO BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB THREE ONE
NINE FIVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
ELEVEN TWO ZERO. BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
FINAL VOTE THIRTEEN TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB THREE TWO
ZERO ONE THE CURRENT VOTERS TEND
TO ZERO BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
HARPER.
YES SIR.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN I'VE FINAL VOTE
FOURTEEN TO SARAH
.
AS PART OF THE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE
HAD ONE MEASURE OFF FILE FILE
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE WAS PULLED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
MR FUNG YOU HAVE THE REQUEST OF
THE COMMITTEE.
GIVE REQUEST OF THE COMMITTEE.
I WAS GET GRANT MISTER TO A
RECONSIDERATION OF.
ITEM TWO.
WITHOUT.
HESITANT SO GET GRANT A
RECONSIDERATION.
I THINK MISTER.
IF THAT. LOOK TO THE CALLS ALL
BUSINESS BEFORE THE.
SOME TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
IS.
WHEN COMPLETED OF THIS HEARING
IS ADJOURNED